sous les flashs des photographes ce
soldat russe se présente à l'audience
préliminaire il est inculpé pour crimes
de guerre une première depuis le début
de l'invasion russe vadim 21 ans est
accusé d'avoir tué un civil près du
village de chupa qui va dans le nord-est
du pays les militaires auraient volé une
voiture puis tiré sur la victime pour
couvrir son méfait pour ce meurtre
présumé il encourt la prison à
perpétuité
sur twitter la procureur général
d'ukraine a souligné l'enjeu du dossier
par ce premier procès nous envoyons un
signal clair chaque auteur chaque
personne qui a ordonné ou aidé à
commettre des crimes en ukraine
n'échappera pas à sa responsabilité
plus de onze mille affaires ont été
transmises au parquet
deux autres militaires russes vont être
jugés ce jeudi ils sont accusés d'avoir
tiré des roquettes sur des bâtiments où
étaient réfugiés des civils dans la
région de kharkiv les forces russes
seraient commis de nombreux crimes de
guerre notamment à abuja dans la
banlieue de kiev la justice ukrainienne
mais aussi les organisations
internationales mènent des enquêtes sur
ces crimes présumés la cour pénale
internationale a annoncé le déploiement
en ukraine d'une équipe de quarante deux
enquêteurs